I want to compliment you I don't I've
known you for a long time and and we've
worked together a little bit and I've
always thought you were hilarious
and I watched your Netflix film last
night and I started to watch it by
myself and this movie starts from the
get-go like the firing gun starts you
show up I think 30 seconds into the film
and I was laughing so hard that I paused
it and I went and found my wife and I
said you have to watch this with me that
honey and so we went back to the start
of the movie and you just kill it you
are so funny in this movie and I'm so
happy for you because I really do think
this is one of those performances that's
going to change everything for you and
I'm really happy thank you so much
that's so nice yeah and I think and I
think coming from me the oh no power
Lauren that I wield in the business this
is huge for me yeah I'm like Spielberg
in you know 87 equivalent because that's
the oh this changes everything but no it
was so funny and you were so funny in so
many different ways and I was
remembering that the first time I saw
you was in a little improv show for kids
called story pirates yes yeah we got to
do that together I mean you didn't get
to do it with me but I got to do it with
you and it was very exciting
it's this theatre company in New York in
LA that takes stories written by
children and adapts them into sketches
and songs and it's really fun and like
really high-quality kids entertainment
and I used to be in that theater company
in New York and LA and we did a show at
the Geffen and we had you as our
celebrity guests and it was so fun on
these I think you sang a song about
wetting your pants which sounds like me
that's an old Gershwin classic the wrong
Missy I think is one of the most popular
films on Netflix yeah yeah yeah I mean
it's it's this is a big deal for you
yeah this is through Adam Sandler's per
day
some company this film and Adam
Sandler's the executive producer and
Adams wife is in the film and then I
noticed and and she does a great job but
then I noticed there's this really
there's this moment where your character
loses it can be incredibly foul-mouthed
can be in all these different ways and
Solaris but there's this moment where
you're yelling at these kids when you
show up at this Resort in Hawaii and I
notice that the kids are Adams kids and
you're being released and I'm like was
Adam on set when that happened he was
there that day and it was kind of like
it was interesting cuz I think for a
little like a little bit I felt more
pressure because he was there of course
and like I you know I liked him I admire
him and I'm like oh I have to like
perform on in front of him but then I
also described and his kids and he just
told me to go harder he was like just
screamed swear at them just go like just
come in hot and I was like okay and and
they liked it they were they were great
but I don't know I'm sure they got it
but do you do you sense in a weird way
that Adam was using you to vent anger at
him
yeah that was really clear actually and
it may be possibly that was the reason
the whole movie existed just have that
one scene there's a part in the movie
where you get fish Chum just fish parts
thrown in your face and it looks really
disgusting and they sell it really well
and I thought would it I'm just hoping
that that was plastic and fake and not
real I have to tell you it was a hundred
percent real because well actually was
supposed to be fake but then the prop
guy told me like the day before like he
pulled me aside and he was like hey that
that fish I was supposed to get this
like fake fish and it didn't arrive in
time and so I'm like I'm gonna use real
fish and I was like yeah that's funny
he's like no I'm like I'm dipping it in
lemon and I'm trying to make it smell
good and I'm taking all the bones out
but it's gonna be real and I was like
okay like it's just like I feel like I
can't I can't argue against that I just
have to go and so then they're just
dumping fish in my you know at Rob
Schneider and you know stuntman or just
throwing actual fish guts in my face and
hair and then people have to debone me
for like an hour on the boat and then we
do it again okay I'm gonna say this on
your behalf that doesn't happen to you
again I understand that you had to do
this too in this movie but I think after
this movie that's done you know how I
can I can stand up for myself and just I
don't know I don't know what you're
supposed to do in that situation that I
mean just like say does make it all CGI
or something I don't know I'll tell you
that
I've been doing the show for whatever
you know 27 years or something and I've
gotten to the point where I'll [ __ ]
about it and be passive-aggressive
yeah like okay well we just won't do it
don't go like no no fine and then I put
on you know a woman's thong and they
brought me into liquid diarrhea I think
I missed that episode it's such a good
episode
it was man it was a themed episode it
was okay your personal perversions my
pro that's perfect yeah that's my
perversion